[Music]
knowing that you know the one that I'm
gonna be taking such as fans tonight you
know what does your reaction that you
talk to it neither women in your life
about it um well you know actually I
talked probably more men than women I
think the women have been to women it
not only in Hollywood but several
industries and communities around the
world have been outspoken and have and
have shown their strength in great
numbers and I think it also takes a
great deal of the men to step up and
ensure their solidarity and and and
voice their outrage and and make sure
that that their voices are heard as well
to that that we're all in solidarity
with with our with our sisters in arms
so to speak so that's why I mean this is
what this pinfall is before it's a he
for she which is a campaign from the UN
women so that's that's my little sign of
solidarity with all the ladies here
tonight you have a role coming up that
is gonna have a lot of eyeballs playing
Andrew Cunanan
yes who is in Versace yes the troubled
young man who unfortunately took
Johnny's life in 97 so yeah that show is
gonna be out in a couple a few weeks if
not I don't know what day or time it is
but I'm here with the cast of that show
and we're all thrilled to to be here
together first time in our public outing
together it's a debutante ball
unfortunately there's not a whole lot of
material on him so it gives me a lot of
leeway to try and fill in the dots
myself but I guess the pressure is more
to remain sensitive to the people whose
lives are still affected by this 15-20
years later so we think about them and
we try to shut some light on things that
maybe we're not some things that
spotlight hadn't been on before
hopefully we can do the victims a bit of
a bit of do justice a little bit
different of a kind of role for you
wouldn't you say sure but the idea is
you're always doing different roles as
an actor you always wanted apart from
the last thing so this was certainly a
wonderful opportunity once the lifetime
opportunity that I'm I was thrilled to
of God and I'm excited for people to to
scrutinize the hell out of me for it